first of all I don't like the term
failure I like the term falling I think
you need those like we fail fast well
the problem with the word fail is it's
like the word cancer right if you have
stage for a lung cancer or stage 4 liver
cancer and you have a mild melanoma with
a 99.999 percent chance of you'll be
fine both of those things are called
cancer and the problem is they're not
the same thing and failure is the same
is the same which is failure could be
absolutely catastrophic or it could be a
minor hiccup but the problem is we call
it failure so I think we need to use
different terms right failure I believe
is something we want to avoid but
falling is something that happens
naturally and we want to fall and get
get up more often that's what I think is
full full fast and get yourself back up
as opposed to lying on the ground and
complaining right so I I want to embrace
falling because that's that's taking
risks that's trying you only fall when
you push the boundaries right the the
the the the language matters because it
changes our mindset especially because
it's too broad a definition for failure
so one of the ways we embrace falling is
by when somebody does fall we don't say
what have you done we go okay try again
as leaders right or how can I help you
fix it and we just a little more relaxed
about it and and we don't swoop in and
do it for them right but rather we go so
in other words we encouraging
risk-taking we're encouraging people to
try recognizing that they won't lose
their jobs that that especially if
you're more junior you really couldn't
do anything that brings down the firm
anyway and we have to give people the
opportunity to fall and let them either
learn to fix their own problems or guide
them so that so that they can every
single one of us has screwed up a
bazillion times and the only reason we
are where we are today is because
somebody said all right all right you're
an idiot but try again you know like
that's where I know who did it for me
Peter and tamashii oh my old bust years
and years and years ago the guy would
never answer any of my questions Peter
what should I do
what do you think we should do my god
if I knew I wouldn't be asking well what
do you think I think we should do this
then do that the guy never had to the
question and if I screw up he goes poof
whoa what are you gonna do you know but
I never felt fear that I would get fired
ever I never felt afraid that my job was
on the line when I screwed up we have to
do that for people
[Music]